the room former Pakistani prime minister
Imran Khan has offered to appear in
court on Saturday police outside his
home in Lahore have been in a tense
standoff with supporters trying to
prevent his arrest Carl's lawyers are
currently trying to negotiate that court
appearance and a de-escalation of the
situation
Khan was ousted as leader last year and
is facing several charges including
corruption which he says are politically
motivated let's speak to Kamal Hyder
who's live for us in Islamabad from what
I hear things got pretty tense outside
his home overnight what is the situation
there now
well indeed there was high tension last
night all night the police was using
tear gas and Imran Khan's supporters
rallying around his house in order to
prevent his arrest now just a little
while ago I spoke to one of the senior
leaders he was the former information
Minister for what surgery who said that
there was another operation that was
underway with most Shilling this time
the paramilitary forces are also present
they are said to have now also
surrounded that compound however these
are dramatic moments indeed because on
the one side the government is
determined to arrest him at the same
time as you can see behind me there are
many satellite dsng trucks and the
focuses on the court the sambad high
court is where the Pakistan telekines
office filed petition are seeking for
the suspension of that arrest warrant so
that heading is underway we are told
that it is likely to be granted but the
next few minutes so next few hours are
going to be critical because if the
court comes out with the decision within
the next few hours and the government is
able to arrest Imran Khan then it will
be another question but indeed across
the country there was protests and that
protest is likely to grow and become
even more intense if Imran Khan is
indeed arrested he has also given an
undertaking that he is going to appear
in court on the 18th that is the date by
which he had to be presented before the
court so dramatic developments in a very
fluid situation okay thank you for that
update Kamal heida there for us in
Islamabad